soziales engagement das sind hat solchen
jetzt gehen sie mir handy
sozialismus das bedeutet ja im prinzip
wie die viel haben sollen dem die
weniger haben etwas abgeben
jetzt haben sie sehr viele süßigkeiten
hier muss man sagen da dürfen sie gerne
was könnte ich vielleicht 20 von mainz
haben 20 von ihren euro aber wir sind
immer noch in einer gesellschaft in der
der einzelne eine bestimmte leistung
erbringen muss zehn euro gleich ist das
prinzip
sie würden mich meine wurst ausgeben
'jetzt wenn du im neuenburger wenn sie
in not jahren würde ich so mein ego
wohnt ebenso kann eine lustige valdez
täte es in not ist lachen muss man halt
auch nicht rüber
[Applaus]
so haben sich jetzt genau mein gesicht
auch das gibt es doch nicht
frau wagenknecht stichwort kapitalismus
jetzt mal ernsthaft freuen sie sich ein
bisschen über den ganzen schlamassel
nicht gerade aber es zeigt natürlich
dass vieles was linke vorhergesagt haben
eben leider auch wirklich so ist und wir
hatten zuerst mal recht vorrang haben
ich wünsche mir vor allem dass unsere
konzepte umgesetzt was bei den linken
die großen schwachstellen nebenleute
lernt also ein leben lang das weiß ich
natürlich zurück wenn man den gedanken
jetzt konsequent weiterdenkt das im
staate allen alles gehört laufe ich
jetzt im prinzip in ihrer unterwäsche
umso vergeben
natürlich nicht sondern wir wollen
wirtschaft eigentum vergesellschaften
und sie müssen sich keine sorgen ihrer
unterwäsche machen sie wollen im prinzip
öffentlich-rechtliche banken da muss ich
ihnen als zdf mitarbeiter sagen
öffentlich-rechtlich das hat noch nie
funktioniert
es ist erstaunlich dass sie als pdf
reader weiter das sagen ich muss ich
muss ihnen sagen in der krise haben sich
gerade sparkassen bewährt das weiß jeder
zuhören wieder zu höher ich hoffe dass
sie es nicht wegschneiden wird und
deshalb
wahnsinn 2 kg eine burg in sachsen
süßigkeiten ein handy und 3 euro 2 sich
jeden tag legten parteitag wäre denn
dann würde ich ganz bestimmt nicht mehr
für dich aber im welke und damit zurück
ins studio mann bin ich lustig oder ist
schlagfertig wie auch